now I know that I'm not supposed to have
an opinion regarding women's issues but
before you cut now I know that I'm
wading into very dangerous territory
with a topic like this because for some
reason I'm technically not allowed to
have any kind of an opinion on an issue
that involves women because some reason
I can't remember oh no oh yes apiece no
it's definitely the penis but I'm gonna
give it the old college try recently
wrote a piece praising Lena Dunham for
coming out in her new book as a rape
survivor let me preface this by saying
that rape is the worst crime a human
being can commit and anyone who does so
deserves a very slow and painful death
and the victims deserve society's full
support and understanding okay okay now
Lena a little Lord Fauntleroy went on to
describe her ill-fated evening of
lovemaking with an infamous on-campus
Republican as a study in the way
revulsion can quickly become desire when
mixed with the right muscle relaxants
okay we'll get to rape culture in a sec
but Lena how about using this previous
experience to teach young girls to you
know use judgment fat drunken stupid is
no way to go through life so to be clear
no booze drugs public urination and the
invitation to have sex still doesn't
make anyone deserving of rape okay okay
she goes on to say that in an attempt to
convince herself that she'd given
consent talks dirty to him as he forces
himself on her okay if at any point
during a sexual encounter the woman
demands that the man stop he must do so
immediately okay okay but if the words
no or I don't want to have sex never
make an appearance talking dirty
directly to a guy could be interpreted
as consent now maybe this guy was a
dirtbag who wouldn't have cared either
way or maybe he heard her demanding that
he mount her amidst her dirty talk and
got some mixed signals
hey Danny party come on in I'm super
glad you're in my house so you want me
here oh yeah totally want you here
oh thanks for inviting me nine-one-one
we have a break-in
breakin what No so we're just gonna try
to rape me now where are your clothes
it's a murky situation murky enough that
Lena Dunham herself didn't consider it
rape the following day when Dunham tells
her roommate Audrey about the encounter
Audrey's were applied by her admission
and tells Dunham you were raped I burst
out laughing
Dunham rights of her initial reaction
you know who wouldn't react that way a
woman who was raped at knifepoint in an
alleyway by a complete stranger the
absolute shattering of her world
wouldn't become mere fodder for a
whodunit conversation amidst her morning
fruit loops I think you might have been
raped last night no come on yeah really
really yeah I'm so sorry
oh my gosh I guess I was totally raped
that woman who has been forcibly raped
often won't come forward to file a
report
not because of slut-shaming or a
male-dominated culture but maybe because
she knows that her case of violent rape
will be placed alongside and given the
exact same priority as the Dunham style
reporting's claiming to be victims of
the exact same crime you did file a
police report right Lena Dunham dance in
Bengal Dorf let's see in order to
protect rape victims I believe that we
need to take the crime very seriously
and not just toss it into the same pot
as regretful decisions or HR infractions
labeling the whole thing rape culture
which by the way feminists have gone on
about rape culture is propagated by men
for years which is untrue for reason a
just as many men are raped as women and
be I have dozens of male friends in
every single time the subject of rape
comes up they all react the same way
with disgust and a passion for severe
punishment for those dirtbags not one
guy says what no I thought we were all a
fan of rape I challenge you to let me
know maybe this rape culture that HuffPo
and Lena Dunham keep going on about
isn't kept alive by lady hating men but
kept alive by people like Dunham willing
to exploit and belittle an absolute
life-shattering crime simply in order to
score political points
maybe it's kept alive by the little boy
who cried rape look I'm sorry I promise
I am NOT here to rape you but like I'm
not traditionally beautiful enough